[Music]
thank you
part two of Ursula Kayla Green's story
dragonfly found in Tales From Earthsea
is titled Ivory and it's really
introducing and focusing on that
character and his interactions with the
character who we had introduced the
titular dragonfly herself also named
irian with her true name
and what we're going to see with him is
he's instrumental in getting eerie and
too Rogue and also helping her to
not necessarily discover but uncover and
get on the way to finding some things
out about herself what it is that she
really values and he's a young but
rather jaded character who as we go
through it it's clear that he thinks
that he is going to dominate and be in
charge but he's actually somebody who is
lesser in comparison to this big woman
erian who is kind of crude and not well
educated and who wants to figure out who
she is through her connection with other
people and in particular through going
to the Isle of Rogue and so we get
introduced to Ivory he's not quite a
wizard and he portrays himself as if
he's the equivalent of in academic terms
somebody being as we call it ABD which
means all all but dissertation when you
are a doctoral or PhD candidate and you
still have to do that final thing people
will sometimes hire you to be a
instructor or a professor on the basis
of an understanding that you are going
to finish your dissertation and you are
going to have that certification from
the people that that do that sort of
thing so there's something very similar
Happening Here with Rogue and we find
out that the master of Erie of westpole
birch wants a wizard with him the
fashion of the time among the nobility
was to have a wizard in their service a
genuine wizard not just some sort of
sorcerer
but a genuine wizard with a staff and a
gray cloak trained on the Isle of the
wise and so the master of eria got
himself a wizard from roke he was
surprised how easy it was to get one if
you paid the price and then we find out
the young man called Ivory did not
actually have his staff in Cloak yet he
explained that he was to be made wizard
when he went back to broke the Masters
had sent him out into the world to gain
experience for all the classes in the
school could not give a man The
Experience he needs to be a wizard Birch
looked a bit dubious at this rightly so
an ivory reassured him that his training
on Rogue had equipped him with every
kind of magic that could be needed in
area of West pool on way and as we find
out later on in part three
um Ivory spends much of his time working
with the hand the master of Illusion
learning how to do all sorts of cool
tricks make fireworks make deer run
through but when it comes to actual
needed magic he actually pawns that off
to other people as we see
whenever Birch had guests from
keppermouth or neighboring domains the
herd of deer the swans and the Fountain
of golden wine made their appearances
but if the Masters Of The Orchards and
Vineyards came to the master to ask if
his wizard might put a spell of increase
on the pairs this year maybe charm the
black rot off the vines on the South
Hill Birch said a wizard of Rogue
doesn't lower himself to such stuff go
to the Village sorcerer to earn his keep
so it's not just Ivory it's also Birch
that are you know giving him a pass on
this and it gets a little bit more
poignant because
Birch's own daughter has this nasty
cough that she just can't seem to shake
and her mother keeps looking at Ivory
you know to to heal her to do the sort
of things that a wizard
ought to be able to do so he's he's not
quite a wizard in more than one respect
and what can we say about the guy he's
arrogant he's selfish you know he
doesn't think about other people's needs
uh and then you know he breaks rules and
he he has justifications for this he's
also bitter and he is lustful now the
lustful thing constitutes a problem
because in Earthsea at the time that
we're talking about here
Mages are supposed to be celibate and
that's going to play a major role in the
story but let's look at a few passages
that reveal to us his motivations and
his character and these these come about
in his conversations with Erie and her
dragonfly
she asks him about the Isle of rock and
he says there are good men there great
and wise the ark Mage certainly was but
he's gone and the Masters some hold
aloof following Arcane knowledge seeking
ever more patterns ever more names but
using their knowledge for nothing others
hide their ambition under the gray cloak
of wisdom Roque is no longer where power
is in Earthsea that's the court in
havner now Rogue lives on its great past
defended by a thousand spells against
the present day and inside those spell
walls what is there quarreling Ambitions
fear of anything new fear of young men
who challenge the power of the old and
at the center nothing an empty Courtyard
the ark Mage will never return so he's
talking about this experience that he's
actually had of being at Rogue and
seeing that the stories that people tell
and sort of the outward facade doesn't
measure up it's kind of hollow it inside
at least in his point of view a little
bit later we have this discussion about
rules
he's proposed to irian something we're
going to talk about that she sneak in
and she says is it allowed and he says I
don't care what's allowed he said with a
frown she'd never seen on his face the
archmage himself said rules are made to
be broken Injustice makes the rules and
courage breaks them if I I have the
courage if you do so she's or he's
presenting himself as being somebody
who's willing and courageous enough to
break the rules that are standing in the
way of getting anything important and
useful done and then finally there's one
other passage that I think that we
should take a look at as well he's
talking here about
um you know what's going on in terms of
women and celibacy and uh he actually is
going to you know say at some point did
you think I was one of their eunuchs
that I'd castrate myself with spells so
I could be holy why do you think I don't
have a staff why do you think I'm not at
the school did you believe everything
that I said there was a scandal produced
by Ivory at Roque and that's why he was
actually expelled from there sent back
out into the world and it has to do with
his own lust but also this bitterness
that he has about all these things that
are put into place you know you could
say traditions and requirements that he
doesn't see a need for so Ivory is going
to meet and befriend and talk with irian
she already has a kind of reputation
um
being you know this this uh interesting
person right uh he asked Birch about
this old house right and Birch says
that's area old area I own that house by
rights
um haven't seen the old man for years he
had a daughter she's called dragonfly
and she does all the work and I saw her
once last year this is actually the
youngest daughter Rose she's tall and
beautiful as a flowering tree right and
uh so yeah so Ivory is like well I
should go and find this woman who is
beautiful as a flowering tree and they
have an encounter first her dogs attack
his horse and uh you know they they have
a brief encounter for a while you know
she does some healing and then uh she
says you're the wizard then and he says
ivory of Havana great port at your
service and she says I thought you were
from Rogue and he says I am
and then she says you lived there you
studied there do you know the ark Mage
yes he said with a smile
and he's he's actually a little bit hurt
himself she and Rose have a long talk
which we've already discussed elsewhere
about you know does does she have to be
careful with this guy and
um a lot of their talking centers around
irian wanting to know all about Rogue
because irian wants to know about
herself and she thinks that there must
be something there
so
um they're they're talking a little bit
later about the arc Mage and about magic
slowly ebbing away and
not being as strong and she says oh if
only I wasn't a woman and he says you're
a beautiful woman why would you want to
be a man so he says so I could go to
Rogue and see and learn why is it that
only men can go there
so it was ordained by the first archmage
centuries ago said Ivory but I too have
wondered you have often he says seeing
only boys and men day after day in the
great house and all the precincts of the
school knowing that the town's women are
Spellbound from so much as setting foot
on the fields about Rogue Knoll once in
years perhaps some great lady is allowed
to come briefly into the outer courts
why is it so are women incapable of
understanding or is it that the Masters
fear them fear to be corrupted
no but fear to that to admit women might
change the rule they cling to the purity
of that rule and dragonfly says women
can live as chastely as men
uh and he says well of course
but witches aren't always chased are
they maybe that's what the Masters are
afraid of
maybe celibacy isn't as as necessary as
the rule of Rogue teaches maybe it's not
a way of keeping the power pure but
keeping the power to themselves leaving
out women leaving out anybody who won't
agree to turn himself into a eunuch to
get that kind of power who knows she
Mage now that would change everything
all the rules and then he says
you could go to Rogue I could help you
get in there you have the heart the
Courage the will of a man you could
enter the great house
and she says well what would I do there
and he says what all the students do
live alone in a stone cell and learn to
be wise it might not be what you dream
it to be but that too you'd learn and so
she says Ah there's there's obstacles to
this and he says
you got a guy on the inside I can help
you get past the doorkeeper I can help
you get there I can do all these things
so he's hatching this plan that she is
going to fall into
seeking out her actual desire not
realizing that he has something
different in mind actually two different
things one is to embarrass if it will
actually work to embarrass the masters
of Rogue so that he can place himself
above them pridefully arrogantly saying
aha see I showed you you stupid people
but the other
is that he's motivated by his desire for
irian his
at some points love at most points lust
and desire perhaps not just to even have
sex but to to dominate to control to
have something over on her as well and
so they they go on and uh there's this
interesting scene where he tries to cast
a spell on her quite early on impatient
with wooing her massive physical
indifference he had worked up a charm a
sorcerer's seduction spell of which he
was contemptuous even as he made it
though he knew it was effective he
casted on her while she was
characteristically mending a cow's
halter the result had not been the
melting eagerness it had produced in
girls he'd used it on in hovnor and
thrill dragonfly had gradually become
silent and Sullen when attentively
approached her taking her hand she
struck him away to the with a blow to
the head that left him dizzy he saw her
stand up and stride out of the stable
yard without a word the ugly Hound she
favored trotting after her the Hound
looked back at him with a grin she took
the path to the old house when his ears
stopped ringing he stole after her
hoping the charm was working and this
was only her particularly uncouth way of
leading him at last to her bed nearby
the house he heard crackery breaking her
the Father the drunkard came wobbling
out looking scared and confused
following by dragonfly's loud harsh
voice out of the house you drunken
crawling traitor you foul Shameless
lecture
she took my cup away the master of eria
said to the stranger she broke it Ivory
departed he did not return for two days
on the third day he wrote experimentally
past old urea and she came striding down
to meet him I'm sorry Ivory she said
looking at him with her Smoky orange
eyes I don't know what came over me the
other day I was angry but not at you I
beg your pardon he forgave her
gracefully he did not try a love charm
on her again soon he thought now he
would not need one he would have real
power over her power to compel where is
that power going to come from
well in order to get in to the aisle of
of roke and the uh to get past the
gatekeeper she's going to have to reveal
her true name and ivory gets her to
reveal her true name Aryan to him which
means that he winds up having
control over her if he chooses to use it
but
interestingly before that something
happens something that shows that
there's he's not completely rotten
inside
um she says Rose always said I had power
but she didn't know of what kind and I
know I do but I don't know what it is
and he says you're going to Rogue to
find out raising his glass uh and he
says and may what you find be all you
seek and she says if I do it will be
thanks to you
and Le Guin tells us in that moment he
loved her for her true heart and would
have foresworn any thought of her but as
His companion in a bold adventure a
gallant joke
then they had to share a room at the
crowded Inn with two other Travelers but
Ivory's thoughts were perfectly chased
though he laughed at himself a little
before it so there's an aspect of ivory
where he he does actually care about her
he does actually love her he does want
to help her on her way he also does want
to have sex with her and we're going to
find out uh this as well irian is going
to trust him and then Ivory is going to
make a revelation to her after this
after she you could say gives in to him
and gives him her her true name
he said nothing in fact he was at a loss
if he had known it would be this easy he
could have said her name and with it the
power to make her do whatever he wanted
days ago weeks ago with a mere pretense
at this crazy scheme without giving up
his salary and his precarious
respectability
he says you know going on she says
what's wrong
and he says
I only wanted to make love to you you
did and he says did you think I was one
of their eunuchs that I'd castrate my
spells so I could be holy why do you
think I don't have a staff why do you
think I'm not at the school did you
believe everything that I said
yes she said I'm sorry and she says we
can make love if you want
and he says well what are you and she
says I don't know that's why I'm going
to Rogue
and um
you know they they choose to to do that
um
he lets her know that really what he'd
done is you know sneak in sneak in a
girl
and that uh you know things are not what
they originally appeared and then he
says uh or the green says it was true he
knew her name irian it was like a coal
of fire a burning ember in his mind his
thought could not hold it his knowledge
could not use it his tongue could not
say it so he can't compel her
she looked at up up at him her sharp
strong face softened by the shadowy
lantern light
if it was only to make love you brought
me here Ivory we can do that if you
still want to
and then he says
I think we've gone past that possibility
and the section ends with him beginning
to instruct her on how she will get into
the great house and pass the doorkeeper